this is Justin hey Walt filling in for
Peter Brown on his no man's sky review
in progress following the unexpected
leak of no man's sky late last week
developer holo games released a
significant day one patch for the game
this morning effectively pulling the rug
out from anyone who got an early start
it resets the state of the games vast
galaxy and all player made research
discoveries it aggressively rebalances
inventory management and the galactic
market in practice no man sky feels
different today than it did yesterday
but in spirit it remains the same we
aren't ready to issue a final review for
no man's sky not because of this new
patch but because we've only just begun
our journey
with a personal spacecraft and a
multi-tool weapon you're free to
adventure around a massive galaxy a net
of 18 quintillion planets the point of
no man's sky is to explore but there's
more than one reason to heed the call
you're lured by a common goal to reach
the center of the galaxy but also by a
distant mysterious force that appears
now and then to steer you into the
darkest corners of the cosmos
nevertheless your priorities are
ultimately in your hands you can ignore
explicit objectives and live a life of
greed if you so wish you can also spend
your time cataloguing discoveries and
leaving your mark on planets which may
someday be discovered by another lone
traveler casual exploration is rewarding
thanks to a wealth of resources outposts
and ancient ruins present on almost
every planet it's hard to remember one
that wasn't littered with lucrative
opportunities the money you earn from
mining and selling resources can now be
spent on new multi-tools in spacecraft
both of which come in numerous colorful
and exotic designs looks aside better
gear also comes with more slots that can
be used to store items or house
equipment upgrades equally important
capabilities in the long term even a few
hours in however there comes a point
where the loop of seeking and acquiring
gear begins to sag and the vastness of
the galaxy sinks in
with an unfathomable universe beckoning
and hundreds of thousands of light-years
separating you from the intended finish
line at the center of the galaxy it
becomes far too easy to question the
meaning of your pursuits no man's sky is
a technical marvel but it's too early to
tell if its enormity comes at a cost
what does it mean to be alive in a world
where everything is driven by algorithms
despite the fact that there is a
tangible formulaic structure beneath it
all no man's sky can instill a grand
sense of wonder on any given moon or
planet the call of a distress beacon
will lure you over the next mountain
where you then discover a cache of rare
minerals and a cave that allows you to
refuel your hyperdrive for another
interstellar leap you may wander so far
in search of random events that the fear
of being stranded on an alien planet
sets in and you long for the familiar
comfort of your cockpit I'll never see
everything there is to see in no man's
sky it's the promise of unforeseen
discoveries that I must continue to
investigate along with the value of
prolonged virtual isolation is it worth
my time to journey into the unknown for
hours in search of treasure that may or
may not exist would I be happier merely
sailing among the Stars rather than
toiling away on radioactive planets in
search of minerals and generous aliens
I'll be chronicling my journey through
no man's sky leading up to the full
review so check back with GameSpot
everyday until then as I plot my course
for the center of the galaxy
you